for me the best part of December is the
anticipation of the movies coming out
next year and 2024 is looking like it
won't disappoint today I'm going to run
down some of the biggest most exciting
titles releasing next year and let you
in on what we know about them so far
January starts with a bang or better yet
it starts with a burn book aka mean
girls is back in theaters on January
12th only it's not a sequel or even
technically a remake of the original
It's actually an adaptation of the
Broadway musical which was based on the
OG movie from 2004 so our favorite group
of high school girls Regina Katie Karen
Gretchen are back on the big screen and
now they'll be singing their hearts out
too the main characters are all played
by new cast members some of whom even
played the roles on Broadway now what
would happen if you made a Spider-Man
movie but decided not to invite Spidey
well you'd get something like Madam Webb
arriving this Valentine's Day it's a
story set in the realm of Spider-Man but
it doesn't feature Mr Parker now this
isn't the first time Sony has tried this
it worked really well with Venom maybe
not so much with morbius but they're
back at it with a female Centric cast of
action Fighters it centers around Dakota
Johnson's character Cassandra Webb who
suddenly has powers to see the future
and naturally she uses it to stop a
baddy from wreaking havoc on her her
friends and the City of New York March
1st brings us the conclusion to the Dune
Saga which started back in 2021 and to
be honest the trailer looks epic
incredible costumes wild makeup and lots
and lots of sand okay maybe that doesn't
sound as cool as it looks but trust me
you're going to love that sand the movie
was actually supposed to come out in
November but the studio didn't want to
release it during the actor strike since
that meant they couldn't do any
publicity for it which I get it's a
great cast that includes Timothy shalam
zindaa Rebecca Ferguson and Javier
Bardem from the first installment and
now they're joined by stars like Leia s
Austin Butler Florence Pew and
Christopher Walkin there are battles
screaming hordes and yes those nose
plugging devices called still suits
which preserve moisture for the
characters Ghostbusters Frozen Empire
picks up right where the last
installment of the franchise
Ghostbusters afterlife left off only
this time the gang is back in New York
City which is where the original
installment began so it's new but also
has a throwback vibe to it the acting
core is Finn wolfard Mckenna Grace
Carrie and Paul Rudd they have to
save New York and presumably the world
from a ghostly force that literally
scares people to death and something
tells me they'll be making a lot of
funny jokes as they do it it arrives on
March 29th these two heavyweights are
back and looking to get into some
trouble on April 12th but before you
assume it's just them fighting from the
opening bell it appears they are
actually allies in this one at least to
start they apparently find out about
about something from underground that
will threaten Earth's survival you know
no biggie it stars Dan Stevens who has
certainly come a long way from starring
in Downtown Abbey cuz this is about as
opposite from that show as it can get
joining him are folks from the first
Godzilla versus Kong movie like Brian
Tyree Henry and Rebecca Hall on May 3rd
this adaptation of a 1980s TV show
arrives starring Ryan Gosling as a
stuntman who's tasked with finding a
missing movie star he Stars opposite
Emily Blunt who plays the director on
the film he's working for as well as a
former flame it's a will they won't they
Vibe with huge effects and action
sequences and Gosling looks like he's
bringing his usual amount of Charisma
self-deprecating humor and overall
handsomeness 2 weeks later on May 17th
if you're looking to cleanse your pallet
with a fun half animated rump you'll
definitely want to head to the theaters
for if starring Ryan Reynolds it posits
a world where ifs AKA Imaginary Friends
are real and Ryan's if voiced by the
ever hilarious Steve Carell is now back
in his life Reynolds and a young girl
played by Kaylee Fleming have to pair up
all the abandoned imaginary friends with
new kids the trailer looks like a lot of
fun and who doesn't love the dry WID of
Sir Deadpool himself May 24th brings us
the prequel to The Classic Mad Max Fury
Road it's about how furiosa this time
played by Ana Taylor Joy is kidnapped as
a youngster and how she Rises up in the
world dominated by immortan Joe Chris
Hemsworth also stars as the villain in
the movie although the only thing anyone
can talk about from the trailer is his
fairly over-the-top prosthetic nose
either way the trailer makes it clear
it's just as epic looking as the first
one and just as action-packed you'll be
able to beat the heat of the summer with
a July 26th trip into the theaters to
see our favorite fourth wall breaking
cursing like a sailor while kicking butt
superhero Deadpool the third installment
of this m MCU FunFest features not only
Ryan Reynolds of course but also Hugh
Jackman that's right Wolverine is
somehow back in the MCU and based on
some BTS footage and photos we've seen
he's wearing the old school Wolverine
costume get ready to watch the most
romanish of bromances between Ryan and
Hugh as they take on whatever forces the
MCU throws at them you'll be able to get
psyched up for Halloween with the
October release of Todd phillips' Joker
sequel while we don't know a ton about
it we know that Wen is back and this
time he's joined by Lady Gaga as Harley
Quinn oh and it's a musical so I guess
expect pretty much anything from this
one clearly Hollywood hasn't skipped a
beat despite all the craziness of 2023
have any that looked particularly good
to you let us know in the comments
section
below